Let's go through these one at a time; now, given any graph, can we say that
clevervc will outperform our factor-2 approximation algorithm, and this is actually false.
Well, it seems like it outperformed our factor-2 approximation algorithm in each case we tested it.
In order to actually verify that it will outperform our other algorithm,
will he either have to test it against every possible graph, which is somewhat impossible
or we would have to give a mathematical proof that clevervc will outperform
our factor-2 approximation algorithm in every circumstance,
and since we haven't done that, we can't actually say that this is true.
We also can't say with certainty that clevervc is a factor 1.75 approximation algorithm,
and that's because well we can't see the source code at all.
If we can't see the code, then we can run test and be more and more certain
whether or not it's a factor 1.75 approximation algorithm,
but we cannot be certain so we can't say that this is true.
However, we can say with certainty that clevervc is not a correct algorithm and why is that.
Let's look back at our table here; now, the key thing to notice here is that
the algorithm were comparing clevervc against is a factor-2 approximation algorithm.
That means that each of these numbers, each of these minimum vertex cover sizes,
is at most twice the actual minimum vertex cover.
So, let's think about what that means.
That means that the minimum vertex cover for 10,000 vertices graph
is actually at least 284, let's go ahead and round up here.
Similarly, the minimum vertex cover for the 20,000 vertices graph must be at least 117.
For the 30,000 vertices graph, the minimum vertex cover has to be
at least 300, and this is the key right here.
So, the absolute minimum vertex cover of this graph has to be at least 300
but clevervc is saying it found one that is only 295.
So, that means that this is wrong.
This cannot possibly be if this is a factor-2 approximation algorithm.
So, either this isn't actually a factor-2 approximation algorithm,
and let's say that we verify that it is,
or this is not a correct algorithm for finding the minimum vertex cover.